the book is titled building a second
brain a proven method to organize your
digital life and unlock your creative
potential what the hell is a second
brain and why does it help you organize
your digital life and unlock your
creative potential yeah it's a great
question uh a second brain think of it
think of things you already do
so you might have a journal imagine if
everything you wrote in that journal or
diary was saved forever was searchable
that you could actually derive insights
from it you could go ask it a question
what have i thought about money in the
past what have i thought about personal
growth how have my dates been in the
past what did i learn you could actually
mine the insights from that that's a
journal or diary now imagine notes you
took from books or articles now imagine
even practical things like grocery lists
packing lists travel itineraries now add
bookmarks from that you save from the
web now add any kind of document that
you've created from the past all these
things are things we largely already do
into some capacity but now imagine
getting all of that material which like
we said is just data
all of that stuff is just information
and you you save it you centralize it
all in one single central place
where you know will be preserved forever
you know you can always search for
things you know you can once it's saved
in the same place start to link things
together start to tag it start to
organize it what would be the value what
would be the
you know what would be the value of the
the aggregated sum of all that material
that's your second brain so a cynic
would say that well what is the value of
that why do i care if my like surely
isn't it a bad thing if my private
journal is in one place for some evil
corporation to access forever
like why do i need to care about my
shopping lists yeah books i've read i've
read a few fiction i've read twilight i
read 50 shades of grey in addition to
getting things done why does it matter
if it's all in one place
yeah i would say a few things if you
make anything
and i'd say more of us are makers or
creators than you would think right if
you're writing long emails if you're
writing reports
memos analyses project plans like most
knowledge workers have some virtually
all knowledge workers have some kind of
output
you can't just sit down and make
something from scratch or if you do it
won't be very good you won't have a lot
of
kind of interesting ideas to add to it
you need as a creative person some
repository some store of
ideas and insights to draw from or else
you're going to be doing that classic
thing that we want to avoid which is
looking at the blank page or looking at
the blank screen right and trying to
come up with an idea which is one of the
worst experiences i would say even
broader than making things think about
decisions
a decision is something that you in a
sense create right you take into account
all this information all these inputs
what your team thinks what your
colleagues think how the economy is
doing what people in your industry say
you are incorporating all of those
inputs into a decision
i would say that is something that you
need to draw on existing material uh any
kind of outcome right like it's
difficult to to go out into the world
sort of naked
in idea terms and make things happen
without any research without any
creative raw material without any
planning yeah it's it's just hard to do
okay
yes so the way that i kind of you know
when people ask me oh what's the deal
with the second brain thing i'm like
it's basically a you know a
digital note-taking system that you can
put anything into and that you can then
use for the things that you actually
care about yeah so i think this is very
easy to give an example to if you're for
example a writer you know there's this
idea of a commonplace book which is a
thing from from back in the day where
anytime you read a book or you have an
insight you have an idea you write it
down in this one book and now if you
have multiple of these books that you've
collected through 10 years of your life
and you come to writing a book you're
like cool i now have all of these
insights i've already gathered i've
already got the raw materials it's
almost like taking notes in class yeah
you if you're then writing an essay
you're mining the notes you've taken in
class doing a little bit of googling but
mostly doing it from stuff we've read in
class wider reading other insights maybe
a little note that sparked when you were
in a lecture and then you're assembling
your essay based on those raw materials
yeah rather than assembling your essay
from the blank page or attempting to
assemble your essay via a google search
where you're just going to be
derailed by
seo content marketers who are writing
the most boring ass listicles to help
drive content for their things exactly
so in a way you're creating your own
google yeah your own sort of external
brain your second brain that you can
then search for relevant things yeah and
i guess that that's that's easy enough
to think about like let's say if you're
a student and you're writing essays easy
enough if you're like a youtuber you're
like cool
i get to mind this for content ideas
what about like
not that not obvious things like that
well what other use cases are there for
a second brain outside the scope of ima
quote content creator student there's
all these little mundane things
just from people's everyday lives like
i'll give one very simple example i'm
driving by the hardware store
as a parent
it's like i have to make use of every
single minute if i'm driving by the
hardware store i want to take advantage
of that opportunity opportunistically no
is there anything that i could just pop
in pull in right here pick it up from
the hardware store which is across town
right
rather than trying to
from my home set aside all this time to
go to the hardware store yeah so how so
here's the question how can i within
seconds
look at some
resource someplace and know all the
things that i might want to pick up at
the hardware store
and i did that i actually have this as a
case as like a micro case study in the
book i i went into my notes went into
the project folder for the studio that
we were building went into one note that
had things to pick up at the hardware
store right which i could have also done
a search for
and then right there in the note i kind
of reorganize it put some things at the
top put some things in a section that
says don't worry about it for now and
that way it's like i can take advantage
of a spontaneous opportunity in my day
which is driving by this hardware store
to also pick up those items which i
would never be able to remember right
and it would also be hard to sit there
in the parking lot and try to like make
a new list and try to remember all the
things that we were talking about two
weeks ago that i have to pick up
okay so it's like your second brain is
is offloading functionality from your
own brain to be forced to remember
things like three weeks from now when i
happen to be swinging by the supermarket
what are the things that i need to grab
yeah and so it's not just like notes
that you're taking from lectures as it
were or videos that you watch books that
you read it's also to-do lists for
projects that you're working on let's
say you're remodeling your studio let's
say you're i don't know getting
something installed in your kitchen
let's say you're trying to make your
bedroom look a little bit nicer yeah
those are all i guess projects yes in
our life yes and unless you're used to
thinking like a productivity nerd you
might not think of them as projects like
yes you know install bookshelf in
bedroom or sort out cable management on
desk setup like i need for that well i
need some cable ties i need one of those
like plastic boxes to put into i need
some kind of cleaning implement for my
keyboard because my keyboard's a
freaking mess um i'm not going to bother
getting those things right now so let's
just chuck them in a to-do list such
that next time i happen to swing by the
hardware store i can just pick up those
things and it becomes a sort of
seamless part of my life is that kind of
the idea yeah i think people sometimes
they think oh second brain this is this
advanced futuristic technology it's
going to be this like you know
exoskeleton that's going to give me new
powers and new capabilities
sure maybe eventually but instead think
about instead of the top of your skill
hierarchy the bottom
what is the stuff that you're trying to
memorize what is the stuff that you're
trying to keep in mind
right you know these little things are
you trying to keep in mind you know your
the homework assignments your kid has to
complete this week that you're helping
them with are you trying to keep in mind
um you know places you want to visit
next time you're in this country are you
trying to keep in mind the ideas from
the meeting with your boss last week are
you trying to keep in mind ideas that
have come up in a marketing meeting you
probably don't even realize it right
because we were never taught oh that
thing you're trying to keep in mind
don't keep that in mind in fact we're
usually taught keep this in mind
remember this like
you can even notice the things people
say in little these little
conversational moments they're like oh
can you can you
remind me of this or keep this in mind
or bring this up next time i'm always
like no i can't i'm a
fickle fragile human being i have to
write it down
so what happens if is if you replace the
instead of adding new levels of thinking
replace the bottom levels which then
frees up your time frees up your
attention frees up your energy which you
can then dedicate to those higher levels
yeah yeah the way i think of it is like
um i think uh it's like
my brain is a dumbass and i don't trust
my brain to remember anything at all and
so if it's important i need to write it
down somewhere yeah and then i need to
remember where i've written it down yeah
and so the more
second nature that becomes and the more
i know that all of my things go in this
folder yeah all my things go in this app
all my things go in this particular
notebook yeah the more likely i am to
remember the things that actually matter
to me exactly and i've i started
applying this in the in the realm of
people as well so i have like a people
folder in my apple notes where um
anytime i have a conversation with
someone and if i remember to do it i'll
just quickly be like oh
had a chat with danny on the 16th of
april 2022 we talked about x he's
thinking of moving to america he'll be
in america for for a month coming back
on the 14th of may
cool that's fine sounds a bit null but
next time i speak to danny which might
be two months later i look at that novel
oh oh yeah he was in america for a week
for a month how was your trip to america
danny and i said oh you remembered uh
and it's like we're totally cool with
writing down people's birthdays yeah as
like oh you know i'm not gonna remember
someone's birthday but i know it's
important that i remember their birthday
so i can send them something and
therefore i'm going to write it down
yeah
but there are also so many things about
like you know people that we know that
we want to remember yeah that we just
don't trust our brain too like i don't
know how old your kid is i don't know
how old francesco's kid is i know that
you guys have kids and maybe sort of
have another kid on the way i i have
dozens of friends around the process of
getting married in the
various stages of pregnancy it's like
how do you keep track of all that it's
important for those individual
relationships but no one would be like
you know if if for example you had a
little address book and you kind of
wrote down details yeah oh there's
something cute about it yeah if you put
it in an app suddenly it's like oh my
god you're being too systematic with
your relationships what is wrong with
you you're a robot etcetera yeah it's so
funny i have a christmas notebook
christmas presents notebook every time i
come across
an item that i think could make a good
gift i just take a clip take a link take
a note and put it in there and then at
the end of the year i just do a matching
i just get a list of everyone i need
presents for open up that notebook it's
it's things i haven't even looked at you
know all year long and then i just go
okay this one for this person this one
for this person as a result everyone
thinks i'm like this incredibly
thoughtful gift giver i'm the worst gift
giver i can't remember anything i can't
remember anniversaries birthdays nothing
but using i've essentially offloaded the
part of my brain that would be
constantly thinking or stressing out at
the end of the year oh shoot how do i
buy all these gifts and i'm just giving
that job to my second brain hey friends
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click here for
the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day